bonjour à toutes et à tous
je m'appelle Caroline juradeau et j'ai
toujours été ambitieuse
j'ai toujours voulu en fait monter un
projet qui me portrait hyper loin je
savais pas comment mais j'étais prête à
faire grosso modo tout ce qu'il faut
quoi
et donc il y a 7 ans quand j'ai lancé ma
première start-up j'ai fait exactement
tout ce qu'on m'a dit
j'ai fait d'abord un business plan sur
cinq ans je mets une que vous savez ce
que c'est et c'est très pénible à faire
ensuite à chaque fois que je croisais
une personne je lui disais on va changer
le monde je le pensais vraiment j'ai
formalisé notre vision notre mission
j'ai fait des tonnes de beaux PowerPoint
en fait ce que je faisais c'est que je
visualisais le succès de ma start-up je
visualisais les 50 salaires
visualiser les millions de levées de
fonds
je visualisais l'hyper croissance et
j'ai un peu honte de le dire mais je
visualisais aussi moi en couverture de
Forbes titrée ils ont changé le monde
j'avais 25 ans et rien ne s'est passé
selon mon plan
en réalité
j'ai recruté 10 personnes j'ai levé 350
000 euros et j'ai fait la croissance
d'une gentille PME ça aurait pu être un
succès mais pour moi à ce moment là
c'est un lamentable échec
donc ce que je fais c'est que je revends
ma start-up au leader de mon marché et
je me rends à l'évidence je ne suis pas
capable de prévoir le succès dans mon
entreprise je vois pas l'avenir en fait
je ne suis pas une visionnaire
et puis par hasard quelque temps après
je commence à m'intéresser au crypto
j'ai pas de mission j'ai pas de vision
j'ai même pas de plan tout ce qui
m'intéresse c'est découvrir cet
écosystème et j'ai une idée en tête
c'est d'en tirer le meilleur parti alors
je commence à produire du contenu dessus
je fais ça un petit peu tous les jours
sans trop y penser
et puis en fait finalement ça fait un an
et demi que j'ai créé un média qui
s'appelle les crypto de Caro c'est un
média multicanal qui est dédié à la
découverte de l'univers crypto
grâce à ça et sans le voir venir je suis
devenue parmi les femmes les plus
visibles sur le secteur mais newsletter
est la plus grosse en France sur
l'éducation à l'univers crypto et je
génère plusieurs centaines de milliers
d'euros de chiffre d'affaires seuls par
an
mais je n'ai pas la moindre idée de là
où je vais
mes amis croient tout ce que je suis
visionnaire et que c'est pour ça que
j'ai choisi le sujet crypto que j'ai
créé cette boîte ce média etc alors
qu'en fait je ne sais absolument pas ce
que je fais
et je trouve ça compliqué en fait de
nous demander de prévoir un succès qui
aurait pu prendre tellement de formes
différentes
ça a pas de sens pour moi pour comment
est-ce qu'on pourrait prévoir alors
qu'on n'a jamais monté une boîte qu'elle
va marcher et qu'en plus elle marchera
de cette façon là comment est-ce qu'on
peut se présenter à un entretien
d'embauche en disant prenez-moi je suis
le meilleur parce que je sais que ça va
marcher on lit pas l'avenir alors c'est
vrai ce visualiser en train de réussir
quand on a un objectif qui est simple
c'est très utile par exemple vous tous
j'imagine que vous espérez tous obtenir
votre diplôme bon je dis pas que ça va
être facile je dis qu'en revanche cet
objectif il est facile à visualiser vous
savez très bien ce que ça veut dire
réussir votre diplôme
pour ça il y a pas mille façons de faire
vous allez à vos cours vous réviser et à
votre à vos partiels vous essayez
d'avoir les meilleures notes
[Musique]
mais réussir dans le business ça veut
dire quoi parce que moi je croyais que
quand j'aurai signé mon premier client
j'aurais réussi ensuite je croyais que
quand j'aurai signé 100000 € de chiffre
d'affaires j'aurais réussi et en fait à
chaque fois que je faisais ça j'avais
pas du tout mais alors pas du tout
l'impression de réussir je me sentais
même un peu rouler parce qu'en fait ben
il y a pas de critères officiel de
succès d'une start-up
et en parlant de ça quand j'avais créé
ma première boîte j'étais dans un espèce
de coworking il y avait une nana que je
croisais assez souvent qui avait l'air
très sympa et un jour je lui dis
hey salut
tu as bientôt fini ton stage j'avais
compris qu'elle était en stage elle me
dit ben oui et toi tu as bientôt fini ta
boîte ça m'a fait littéralement bugger
parce qu'elle a mis le doigt sur le vrai
problème que je rencontrais il y a pas
de critères officiels de avoir fini sa
boîte il y a pas de ligne de succès ou
d'échec
c'était hyper compliqué pour moi
et en fait ce que ça voulait dire c'est
que Ben puisqu'il n'y a pas de critères
de succès ou d'échec le succès pour moi
il ne peut arriver que par hasard
d'ailleurs il y a pas un seul génie sur
terre qui a réussi à prévoir qu'il
allait avoir du succès et si les génies
ne peuvent pas le prévoir comment est-ce
que nous on pourrait
moi ce que je pense c'est qu'on n'a pas
besoin de plan sur 10 ans ou d'objectif
hyper clair pour réussir
le succès en fait ce que c'est c'est une
situation inattendue au cours de
laquelle son auteur a su tirer le
meilleur parti et éventuellement dont
l'histoire a été réécrite à posteriori
pour donner l'impression qu'il était un
petit peu visionnaire
regardez par exemple snapchat
à la base quand ils ont créé
l'application ce qu'ils imaginaient
c'était que ça allait plaire à des
adultes consentants qui s'enverraient
des photocopines ça a pas du tout marché
par contre dans les lycées avec des ados
qui se font chier en cours ça a été un
carton ils en ont tiré le meilleur parti
le mec qui a inventé les post-its
à faire c'était une colle extraordinte
il a fait l'exact opposé il a réussi à
en tirer le meilleur parti et même la
tarte des célèbres sur tatin c'était
simplement une tarte aux pommes
classique qui a été renversée par erreur
dans le four elles en ont tiré le
meilleur parti
en fait toutes ces situations là ce sont
des situations inattendues dont leurs
auteurs ont su tirés le meilleur parti
alors que ça aurait pu être des échecs
et moi ce que je pense c'est qu'il y a
trop visualiser son succès on s'enferme
dedans et on est perdant à tous les
coups si jamais on réussit ben on est
même pas tellement satisfait parce qu'on
se rend bien compte que c'était une
ligne d'arrivée fictive c'est ce qui
m'est arrivé quand j'ai fait mes
premières ventes et si jamais on échoue
bon ben on échoue donc on est dégoûté
quoi
alors encore une fois c'est vrai si vous
avez un marathon à courir vous
visualisez en train de passer la ligne
d'arrivée c'est évident que ça va vous
aider à vous motiver à vous entraîner et
vous irez plus loin
mais dans l'entreprise dans le business
en général il y a tellement de façons de
réussir il y a plus de 1000 façons de
réussir que vous et moi on n'est pas
compétent pour savoir quelle va être la
manière par laquelle ça va se dérouler
pour nous
et donc je trouve que sans fermer dedans
c'est une erreur
après j'ai bien conscience que là ce que
je vous dis c'est ça ne sert à rien de
visualiser votre succès mais ça veut pas
dire que
même si moi j'estime qu'être visionnaire
c'est un mythe il y a pas des choses qui
concrètement peuvent vous aider à
atteindre une forme de succès j'en ai
compris quelques-unes et je vais vous
les partager par exemple il faut
produire beaucoup il y a un gars qui
s'appelle Simon thon c'est un
psychologue il a écrit une étude en 97
et ce qui disait dans cette étude c'est
que plus les créateurs alors il a
vraiment étudié les créateurs les
inventeurs les entrepreneurs etc et il a
remarqué que plus tu crées d'oeuvre plus
tu avais de chance d'avoir une oeuvre
qui est considérée par la communauté
comme étant remarquable
en fait il y avait pas des gens qui
faisaient que des oeuvres remarquables
et des gens qui faisaient des trucs nuls
c'était juste plus tu crées plus tu as
de chances de faire quelque chose de
remarquable et moi j'ai décidé de le
faire donc chaque jour je produis
quelque chose de concret qui va faire
avancer mon business chaque jour je vais
poster une vidéo et chaque jour et
chaque semaine soyons honnêtes j'ai créé
un article et ça fait effet boule de
neige c'est la loi de la quantité
après j'avoue
que quand mes amis me disent mais tu le
savais Caro c'est sûr tu es visionnaire
j'ai pas tellement envie de leur dire
qu'il se trompe mais je suis quand même
obligé de rétablir la vérité non j'avais
pas la moindre idée de si ce que je
faisais ça allait marcher et d'ailleurs
je pense que s'il y en a autour de vous
qui vous disent à posteriori qu'il
savait que ça allait marcher il vous
mentent pour avoir l'air un peu plus
cool en revanche il y a quelque chose
que je fais et que vous devriez tous
faire c'est que je suis à l'affût
vraiment je recherche les signaux
faibles les indices de croissance je
vais vous donner un exemple simple ma
newsletter c'est aujourd'hui le produit
central de mon média c'est grâce à elle
que j'ai fait autant de croissance et
ben au départ je j'étais seulement
présente sur les réseaux sociaux et je
recevais tellement de questions sur les
crypto que je savais pas comment y
répondre j'avais vachement envie de me
sauver du temps mais en même temps
j'étais pas prête à m'investir dans un
grand projet alors je me suis dit Caro
tu vas écrire 5 emails dans ces 5 emails
tu vas répondre plus grande question que
les gens te posent et comme ça tu auras
gagné ton temps donc j'envoie le premier
email et j'ai 300 personnes qui le
lisent la semaine d'après j'envoie
l'e-mail 2 et j'ai 1000 personnes qui me
lisent et là je comprends le truc ça
c'est un indice de croissance donc j'ai
décidé de suivre ça et ça a pas du tout
été compliqué pour moi de le suivre
parce qu'en fait j'avais pas de plan
donc j'étais pas enfermé dans une
manière de faire qui était censée
m'amener au succès j'étais juste ben
j'ai juste pu changer et me dire vers là
il y a du succès donc j'y vais parce que
ça m'intéresse ça pas été douloureux je
trouve que quand tu as un plan précis et
je l'ai déjà fait et ben pour changer il
faut admettre d'avoir eu tort il faut se
remettre en question c'est super
douloureux
et d'ailleurs c'est quasiment impossible
de savoir qu'on va réussir à l'avance
parce qu'on n'est pas devant on sait pas
lire l'avenir et c'est pour ça que être
visionnaire c'est énormément de
responsabilités il faut se dire moi je
vais réussir et je vais réussir de cette
manière et je vais faire ça et c'est
seulement si jamais tu arrives au bon au
bout à réussir que tu aies été
visionnaire mais presque personne fait
ça alors que finalement ce que moi je me
dis c'est que les meilleurs
entrepreneurs ce sont pas des
visionnaires ce sont des explorateurs
sont des gens qui vont suivre des
indices de signaux faibles et qui vont
avancer beaucoup plus vite et beaucoup
plus loin moi j'ai échoué en tant que
visionnaire mais je trouve le succès
dans l'exploration et ça vous pouvez
tous le faire